it's ordering tacos and there was a guy
in line in front of me and he tried to
order his food in Spanish and then like
halfway through his order he just
realized that he couldn't speak Spanish
he was like hola um tres poyo tacos
porfavor II own carnitas burrito
I haven't sevilla dairy allergy so I
know cheese or sour cream on my plate
that's very important
I'll die and give me the pork well done
and the sauce on the side okay gracias I
used to work with this guy this uh this
black guy and one time we were talking
and he goes white people are crazy you
guys kill your whole family because your
dog told you to I was like well maybe
that's a white guy thing but who's
saying no to a talking dog
yeah I wouldn't look at talking dog in
the face and tell it no I'd be like
please don't stop hanging out with me
you're a dog that can talk and I can
make another family I think maybe I want
my own family someday not cuz I like
kids but I was watching a movie the
other night and this guy in the movie
was getting robbed and he was like
please don't kill me I have a family I
was like what do you say when you're
like 43 with no kids
and that's happening to you you like
don't shoot I've never seen the wire no
my screenplay is not finished don't
shoot I have a Target gift card with
like $15 left on it I'd like to use it I
am I'm having a good year that way I
quit smoking and yeah that's nice people
applauded when you say that but nobody
should smoke cigarettes like they're so
bad for you they're the only vice that
don't have a magazine everything else
has one there's like beer and wine
magazines there's a cigar aficionado you
never even meet like a cigarette
aficionado like some guy who's like this
one it's one of my favorites
it contains little glass pieces that cut
up your lungs and allow more nicotine to
flow through your body
this pens nice with malt liquor and
getting fired from the post office thank
you this I hope I don't bring you down
here but I was reading an article the
other day it was about this guy they
were calling him the worst pedophile and
they think he had over a hundred victims
good night everybody that's my
[Laughter]
what if I did in the set that way though
you know it's not all fun and games
protect your kids
nobody they're calling him the worst
pedophile but then I was like I don't
know if that's the worst pedophile
that's like the best pedophile
I mean just because when I hear worse
pedophile that's a guy who like can
never get his van to start he just buys
candy that nobody likes he's at the
playground with like black licorice and
circus peanuts like what kid doesn't
like Necco wafers I don't understand or
he probably doesn't even have candy he's
probably got like raisins and trail mix
uh-huh
and WNBA cards usually guy kids you like
lady basketball huh who's your favorite
Seattle storm player guys like the
Indiana Fever
you